friends
if i was to say
some words
about romance if i was to say some words
about love if i was to say some words
about the
kind of intimacy
that nourishes us the kind of intimacy
that matters the kind of intimacy that
we measure our
love
and our lives
by
i would speak about the necessity of
soul mating with somebody if you're not
going to bear
your soul
if you're not going to show yourself
fully to someone
don't waste your time
the price is nothing less than
everything the kind of
love that i'm interested in is the one
that takes no
prisoners what came up for me today was
a very clear
[ __ ] yes
that goes
soul mate
or no mate
soul mate
or no mate why waste our times on
anything less than everything why waste
our time
on anything less than the full price of
admission i want to show myself fully i
want to see you
deeply soul mate or no mate let us meet
in archetypal realms let us become
mythopoetic let us slow dance in a
cosmology of two let us create a
inter-subjective life world together
friends soul mate or no
mate to make the journey and never fall
deeply in love
well
it's like you haven't lived a life
at all
there's that great line in the film meet
joe black when anthony hopkins tells his
daughter the kind of love he wants for
her soul mate or no mate he says i want
you to get swept away i want you to
levitate i want you to sing with rapture
and dance like a dervish
like he wants for his daughter to be
elevated
to be exalted
by a soul mate experience
soul mate
or no mate friends
soul mate
or no mate